the batman brings a riddler to life in a
brutal new way courtesy of actor paul
dano who gives the villain a sinister
edge which brutal act is the worst of
the worst caution spoilers ahead
what is the price for your blind
the riddler begins as edward nashton a
former resident of an orphanage once run
by thomas and martha wayne bruce wayne's
parents when edward and bruce were
children thomas announced his run for
mayor of gotham city bertie and martha
were killed shortly afterward leaving
his promises of change unfulfilled in
the final act of the film the riddler
has been captured and incarcerated in
arkham state hospital burst has left
clues indicating he has one final act of
mayhem plan batman interrogates him and
learns that edward has held a grudge
against him since he was a child when
thomas and martha wayne were murdered
the public's attention was focused
entirely on young bruce this left the
orphanage forgotten whose terrible
living conditions edward describes to
batman in painful detail while edward
can't be entirely blamed for feeling
jealous of someone who lived in a
mansion while he'd suffered in a
run-down orphanage that's no excuse for
taking things out on an entire city
that's part of his plan to bring down
gotham city's elite and reveal their
darkest secrets the riddler cultivates a
large online following that is able to
carry out his mission even in the event
of his capture he does this by releasing
videos of himself committing crimes and
declaring his vengeance on the corrupt
rulers of the city this vengeance plays
out in full when the riddler is
incarcerated in arkham state hospital
when he's interrogated by batman he
reveals that he has placed car bombs
throughout gotham city the bombs go off
destroying gotham's breakwater walls
which causes considerable damage when
the city is flooded the sub-people is
all part of the riddler's scheme the
chaos acts as a distraction enabling his
cult-like followers to carry out the
assassination of mayor-elect bella
royale however with the help of catwoman
batman is able to take down the
riddler's fans and prevent the
assassination from taking place it's not
enough that the riddler enacts a large
number of heinous acts throughout the
film he also films them and releases the
footage to inspire gotham city's wayward
minds this elevates aridler from a
common criminal into a genuine monster
as mudbass carmine falcone's crimes
against the city are exposed the
catwoman vows to kill falcone who is
also her estranged father she takes off
for the iceberg lounge with batman and
gordon following closely behind when she
gets into falcone's office catwoman
points a gun at him but before she can
fire a fatal shot batman stops her he
turns falconi over to gordon and the
gotham city police department after he's
read his rights the penguin pulls out
again and prepares to kill falcone
himself but then falcone is shot dead by
the riddler instead who's in sconce in a
nearby building falcone is no angel
having committed plenty of crimes all
over gotham city over the course of
decades but this is one of many murders
riddler commits throughout the course of
the film given that it's simply a kill
with a gun actually makes it one of the
tamest the worst are yet to come i'm
just here to unmask the truth about this
at the point in time the batman takes
place james gordon has not yet risen to
the rank of police commissioner the role
he's most associated with as a character
instead the commissioner of the gotham
city police department is pete savage in
stark contrast to gordon's steadfast
morality savage is deeply corrupt having
accepted bribes from various criminals
shortly after mayor don mitchell jr is
killed by the riddler commissioner
savage holds a press conference he
announces the terrible news and promises
to bring the riddler to justice for his
crime however before he can carry out
this vow he's killed by the riddler the
villain leaves a message for batman and
releases a disturbing video of savage's
death to the public what makes this kill
so disturbing is how riddler does it by
trapping savage's head in a twisted maze
with some hungry rats distributing the
footage of the killing makes us an
especially cold-blooded crime
district attorney gil coulson is another
respected yet crooked member of gotham
city's elite batman discovers early on
that he's working for crime boss carmine
falcone however this doesn't make his
death at the ridler's hands any less
appalling during a funeral service for
the late mayor don mitchell jr a car
careens into the church where everyone
is gathered out comes colson who has a
phone attached to his hand and a bomb
attached to his neck bruce wayne who is
attending the funeral leaves then
returns as batman to talk to the riddler
via the phone in coulson's hand the
riddler threatens to set off the bomb
unless coulson can correctly answer his
three riddles with the batman's help
coulson manages to answer the first two
but he can't bring himself to answer the
third which would reveal the informant
to help the gotham city police
department bring down crime boss
salvatore moroni
the riddler proceeds to detonate the
bomb killing coulson and sending batman
flying backward so let's recap the
riddler ruins a funeral service for the
mayor he killed kidnaps and torments the
district attorney and then horrifically
murders him as if that's not bad enough
he also broadcasts the event live to his
growing online audience
the riddler's worst moment is also his
first brutally killing the mayor of
gotham city don mitchell jr on halloween
night it's a brazen way to kick off his
vicious campaign and he couldn't have
done it in a more cold-blooded way
shortly after watching news coverage of
mitchell's mayoral debate with bella
real the riddler sneaks into his home
and viciously beats him to death he
leaves mitchell's body propped up on a
chair with his head wrapped in duct tape
with the words no more lies scrawled
across his face to add to the
gruesomeness of this crime mitchell's
sum is removed and later found attached
to a usb drive in his car giving new
meaning to the phrase thumb drive the
drive contains photos of mitchell with
another woman revealing that he was
having an affair when batman and gordon
plug the drive in it automatically leaks
the photos to the media he kills a man
and then completely obliterates his
legacy and as you may recall his funeral
after the fact thanks to the riddler's
cruelty mitchell's wife and child don't
just lose him they lose their good
memories of him too check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the batman are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you